Hello, everybody. My name is Markiplier and welcome back to Bad Dream: Coma
Now we're going into "an apartment," and I don't know what apartment. We're going-
OOOOHHHHHHHH
I don't know what apartment we're going into but we'll find out very soon
Ah
This looks lovely
What a great place, we've got here.
OH, delightful
Hello. How are you doing? Yes, I'll come right in. Thank you
Ohhhh, I didn't do thaaat
Ahh, okay
Crowbar? Nah.
Coin-o? No.
Glove. Fireee- no.
Okay, fine then.
Something's going on here
Hello?
Electrical service for premises number one has been turned off.
The service will be restored after paying the overdue bill.
What kind of world do we live in?
Is someone's greatest fear in this coma not paying their bills?
*doorbell*
DING DONG!
Dorng dong
Can I take that?
Ding dong!
hello?
Hello?
HELLO?
Anybody there? No? Alright.
That's it. So I got to go forward so let's try to-
Oh! Letter!
OH!
What if I- what if I drop this...
In the mail? Ok
So I got to do something with this electricity bill before this will be restored
Right
Ooh! Key!
OH NEVERMIND THEN! I'M GOING IN
AH, darkness my friend
Okay
AHHHH
I don't like that.
I don't like that. I can barely see, but I can see a little bit which worries me
Hello? Ah, good.
OHH, bright
Klunk. Why is that so dark in there?
"I urgently need money to continue the treatment.
I hope the Tooth Fairy will help me again...
If I don't give money quickly then there's nothing left, but believing in Magic..."
Well, you're kinda in a coma world, but have you been pulling out your teeth?
Placing it under your pillow?
That seems
Not fun
Why?
What the hell just happened?
OH HI, what a lovely family you have there
Oh, I got a button
Ayy- WHY?
What the fuck is happening?
Whoa boy
Ah dark, great. Still Dark.
Hello.
Light!
WHY-
Is any of this?
Hello, what a lovely family
Wait, I remember that house
Do I remember that house from before?
Does anyone remember?
Uuuuhhh
Uuuhhh
Puzzle pieces are poozling together
The key fell into the toilet again. Great. Can you get it?
No? Who are you talking to? Me?
OH found a pen! Okay
Can I- okay I got to be able to write on this, right?
It's got to be a world
where I can set the paper down right on it and then put it in the mailbox or get some money to put with it
Maybe they got some money here that I can steal
Alright, so there's got to be some money somewhere
because I got a pen
ZOOM
Apparently
What have we got over here? Oh the piggy bank!
Can I smash open the pogey bornk (piggy bank)?
Unhh, put a fake coin in there?
Wha- oh! Put that in there! Sign it?
No. Put a fake coin in there?
Put a button in there. No? Okay, fine.
That's almost there
I get it
Alright I got it, I'm gettin' it
Skoosh
Alright anything else over here?
There's got to be something to do with those Piggy banks, right?
It's got to be something to do with that
OH, I put a fake point in there
Maybe that means they put a real coin- *GASP*
'CAUSE THE FIVE WAS BACKWARDS
OOHHH
Break open you~
I got a coin~ x2
I'm gonna write on this electricity bill~
Okay that's weird, but alright, whatever~
What do I need? What else do I need to write- oh, I need a stamp
I gotta find a stamp, don't I?
I don't know where I'm gonna find a stormp (stamp)
Where gonna- where am I gonna find a stoop (stamp)?
I don't have a stoop
Mm
OOHHH THE PEN! THE PEN IT WA- OH MY GOD the pen made more!
What the hell is with that?
What is with that? That's so weird! I've literally made this place
What the hell?
Oh- WHOAAHHH I don't like thaaat
Who's providing all of this GOO?
Oh, alright then. That was fun, I'm glad that happened...
Well, there's got to be something down here, right? Gotta be something else down here
Yeah, but I don't have...
I don't have anything with which to do anything about this yet
so maybe not yet, down here
But that did add something. So maybe that changed something else cuz sometimes you have to do something before you can actually like...
Hey birdy! How you doing bird?
Bird! Would you like a button? Give a button to bird nnn- the last time
OH
Hello! I got a foos (fuse)! Okay, so maybe if I put the foos in on the other side
Foos? Did that do something? Pen? Gonna make you all better
What did that do?
What that do?
That did something- ah! Lights, I dunno
Oh! In here. Yes, please yes, give me the key in the turlet (toilet)
HELLOOO?
Aiyee- Heidi Heidi, ho~
Is there a key in the turlet (toilet)?~ Okay, so it's not here yet
That did something, but not enough
Making progress, but very piecemeal
Very slowly, very still
So eventually
Eventually I'll have to get that fuse back up. Now, I don't know why they got their bathrooms under power lock but you know
OH, what the hell was that? Wha- oh my God I've been looking for this stamp for everywhere!
AWW, well now it's- *Mark noises* it's the tiniest details, so hard to find
Anyway there we go! Bloomp! Got that all done
Alright good, now what? I gotta get the power back on, but it's back on anyway
There's a- what is that? A board game?
A ploonger (plunger)? Well, I can use the ploonger on the other toilet, which I guess is good
So let me go over to the other world because apparently I was solving this puzzle before I even got to the point where I needed to solve the puzzle
SPLOOSH give me that key because for some reason there's a lot of keys in toilets
Nevermind
Hello? Excuse you?
Scoop shu?
OHH, maybe it's in the basement. Wait, maybe it flushed down to the basement because there was a bunch of skoosh juice coming to-
Yes! That's a hammer. That's a key, but I don't know why there's a hammer there. There wasn't a hammer before there
Was there?
I got a key! Come on, it's a key- ARG come on, fine. Fook you
Alright, maybe the key to the other place? AH COME ON
That one? A cassette?
Well, there was a radio in the mirror world in this room.
Cassette?
*ding dong*
Hello, I'm home! I don't like that
Hello? Help- HELP YOU?
I'll take this paperclip. Thank you. I don't know who you want to help from I can't even help myself at this point
Who's calling for help?
Huh?
Who's calling for help? Wait. OH, whoa?
Hello?
Living room, who's in here? Why did I- why did I pick up a hot dog? Why is that the first thing I did?
637-511
I can't dial that, but 637-511
Oh
I got a die for my board game, great. 6 thoo 7-511
637-511 okay
Great
Goody, I got a hawut (hot) dog, I got a SAHsage (sausage)
Specifically, I got a sausage 637-511
Oh! Hello, okay, sure
Aaah
Ohh
Why does that look like I want to be the guy and why does that look like Trogdor?
That's weird. Alright, how about a dice? I'll roll it hi-ya
Okay
What did I do? You want a sausage? You want a button? Okay I did that. Oooh alright
What did I just do?
OH what no?
I didn't mean to do that. Don't do that to me, come on!
OH DON- okay, good alright
You sack of shit, if you would have done that, I would have been *Mark noise*
I would have been very nmupset (upset)
Okay, I would have been very me nmupset (upset). Can I burn it? Burn it all down
Whoa! Four
Okay
Three! Okay
Four, alrighty then
Glove
Four, alright. Six, okey, six
Okay doing good so far. I don't know if there's any way not to do good. Ooh four four
Five
Three
Doing good, doing good, doing real good. Four, oh boy, yi-AH I've been burned!
Ah, I got fucked
Ah shit, well I guess I just got to keep playing this, huh? Yuhh, just barely not- come on AHHH ya fucked me
AWWW, you fucked me. Ah- OHHHH! AWW?
Come on
Oh boy, come on. Lit luck me. Don't lit muck luck me like that. Don't luck me like that
AGHH give it to me! Euuoohhh
Alright, don't
Euughh
Eughh don't
Ah that's such bullshit. Okay well, this is gonna be a while, I'll be back when this works
There we go! Eat dicks. Man, that took a while
There was some- hey! Look, I played your game. I did it. I'm such a cool pers-
Hi, who are you? Who are you? Who the hell are you?  Why you got teddy bear on your shirt. Do you have a teddy bear?
Do you have an imaginary friend that's a teddy bear?
"Where did you get my game?
I wanted to get rid of it because it seemed dumb to me.
We can't afford a computer. So for now, I need to make board games
There's little we can afford. My parents treatment costs a great deal of money.
As long as you've already played it, tell me if you really like it. I'd like to design games one day
Anyway, what are you doing here? My parents sent you here? I don't know where they are
I'm afraid the death may have got them. I'm worried about them so much
Maybe they went to our old house, the one near the forest.
Could you look for them there? I'm too little to go there alone
Anyway, I have to watch the house. You don't need to worry about me.
I'm very brave and smart."
Mark: Just like me
Dot dot dot
"Just go. I'm worried about my parents."
Okay
OH alright, then I di- *Mark noises* I didn't knooow
I didn't knooow. Okay, alright then. Well, that's the end of that chapter
Oh man, so that kid must be
Like the source of all this, right? Or the reason that death was stopped. Maybe he created a game. I have no idea it's- it's-
It's confusing, but we're getting to the bottom of it
So thank you everybody so much for watching!
Let me know what you think down in the comments below
And as always,
I will see you
In the next video!
BUH BYE!